harvesting season in Wartime Ukraine
navigating Open Fields near the Russian
border means risking landmines and
unexploded bombs always keeping one eye
on the sky for drones missiles and
Russian Artillery
it could just be one of the most
dangerous jobs in the world
people's lives are a priority we only
work when we know it's safe and there is
no threat to life we take every
precaution some of our fields are mind
there are other fields we cannot get to
because the roads are mined much of the
farms in Sumi region are no-go areas
because of Russian Munitions Left Behind
or Ukrainian landmines placed there as a
deterrent
when a Russian shell hit her Farm
Tatiana lost 27 head of cattle
she describes unrelenting Russian
attacks and says Sumi needs more help
Russians fly drones every day and watch
what is happening here they spot us an
open fire they are shooting at civilians
there is no military here and they know
this but they still open fire damage
from artillery and shelling is fairly
common in places like this in the Sumi
region and that's because we're only a
few kilometers away from the border
Russian positions are said to be just
beyond those power lines behind me but
this is not a normal front line there
are no tanks or trenches or troop
movements nonetheless communities here
say they come under attack on a near
daily basis just as we arrived a drone
dropped grenades damaging a nearby cell
tower further isolating people here
a Russian attack also damaged the local
school and leveled the only Hospital in
this Village
many have left
those still here show signs of stress
and depression
it is fair what else is there to say I'm
considering leaving I have two children
and it's terrifying to live here I feel
terrible I feel that I don't want to do
anything I can't get used to it
the D mining worked to make Farmland
viable again could take 10 years and
will only begin after the war
for now Russia continues to Target
entire Villages near the border
ukrainians carry on unwilling to leave
but Unsure how much longer they can stay
Zain basavi al-jazeera Kendra tifka
Village in Ukraine Sumi region
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera